well good evening everybody I'm Bob
Bogomolny president of the University of
Baltimore and it's my pleasure to
welcome all of you on behalf of the
University of Baltimore community to
this evening's event our speaker and
guests is Jeff Kluger who's a 1979
graduate of the University of Baltimore
School of Law and I always feel that one
of the best ways to measure and get a
sense about a university is by looking
at its graduates and we are happy to
have him as an example of a person who
studied here and I must say from my own
standpoint one of the great pleasures of
my activity is being able to spend time
getting to know our graduates and the
wonderful things that they've done as
you'll hear mr. cloggers career is
extended beyond the conventional path of
the law and that really reaffirms the
belief that I have that a law school
education can lead to so many things it
provides you opportunities for a wide
range of activities and the emphasis on
critical thinking the use of language
reasoning is one of the hallmarks of all
that and every once in a while it even
can sort of prepare you to be university
presidents so you never know how these
things turn out on a personal note many
of you know I had a career in the
pharmaceutical industry and in ancient
days well before you even started law
school I actually edit a book on human
experimentation so the field of drug
development and the whole idea of
dealing with critical illness through
science has been a great interest of
mine for many many years and I look
forward today to these discussions at
this point I'd like to ask Dean Holmes
to come down to introduce our speaker
good evening everyone thank you for
coming out I'm Gilbert Holmes I'm the
Dean of the University of Baltimore
School of Law and I'm absolutely
delighted to have you here today
our law school takes great pride in our
alumni and Jeff Kluger is no exception I
met Jeff last fall during an alumni
visit to New York City and when he
described this project that he was
working on
I said well Jeff you've got to come to
the University and let us host your
unveiling of your book in your hometown
Jeff is a native of Pikesville and so
this is his hometown coming out and in
fact his mother splash is here and I
know that regardless of how old you get
mom always likes to come to your
recitals
so welcome splash to this event Jeff is
a 79 graduate of the law school he's a
senior writer for Time magazine and has
been in that position since 1998 he was
a contributor at time for two years
before that one of one of his writings
or his writings have included a book
that he wrote with Jim Lovell called the
lost moon and that book served as the
basis for the Ron Howard movie Apollo 13
and so he had lots of opportunities to
understand science and the like and in
fact has taught science journalism at
New York University our law school for
20 since 1925 has been empowering legal
systems Jeff Kluger proves to us that we
actually empower more than legal systems
and you're in for a great time
Jeff spent some time with students today
at lunch talking to them about
alternative careers and I got an
opportunity to sit in on part of that
and found out that he's a very warm
engaging humorous individual who's a
great storyteller so sit back relax and
be ready for a great time and story from
our alum and author Jeff Krueger
thank you very much
you know it's puts me in mind of the the
first time I was anywhere near a stage
at the University of Baltimore was in
the fall of 1976 when I was an incoming
law student and was attending the
orientation session for four new
students and we were in the auditorium
over at the law school for a session
being conducted by a professor brilliant
and fearsome professor royalty Shannon
house property professor I don't know
how many people remember him and I
remember being in the audience knowing
that he was going to call on a poor
unfortunate bring that person up to the
stage and grill him mercilessly on a
case we had all read he did call a name
which blessedly was not my own guy came
up to the stage and was in his own
anxiety positively smother in the
microphone you could have heard his
voice on Pratt Street it was right on
top of it and professor Shannon house
said in his singular voice don't eat the
microphone just stand in a reasonable
propinquity thereto and I thought I am
over my head already I am just I'm
completely out of my depth so it's nice
to be back and be a little calmer than I
was 28 years ago I wanted to I'm gonna
read a couple of short passages from
from this book but um but I did want to
talk a little bit about what drew me to
the story of Jonas Salk and the polio
vaccine and it was it was more than
being a child of the mid-century I was
born in 1954 just the year they started
testing the polio vaccines so like every
other child born then and earlier I was
living at the mercy of my immune system
and the the lottery of the the luck of
the the viral draw I dodged that bullet
as as as the large majority of kids did
but the stakes for being in the small
minority were so huge and the suffering
so profound that even though most most
boys and girls escaped it it was hard to
escape the shadow of it one of the a lot
of what drew me to to the story of Jonas
Salk
was similar to what drew me to the story
of Apollo 13 for me a lot of pneumatic
roads run to and from that story in both
cases there was a very very clear
narrative arc the story of Apollo 13
played out over just six days in the
confines of a spacecraft two spacecraft
actually the story of the polio vaccine
plays out literally over millennia but
the truly intensive truly focused work
on the project particularly from sulks
point of view covered just three years
from 1952 to 1955 and took place almost
exclusively on the first three floors of
municipal hospital at the University of
Pittsburgh in both cases there was also
a ticking clock in the case of Apollo 13
that ticking clock was the exhaustion of
the consumables consumables being air
water and power when they were exhausted
so with the lives of the astronauts be
in the case of Apollo of of the Salk
story it was more of a kalindra chol
clock it was a clock that began taking
every April as soon as the weather grew
warm and the hot pocket of the Bayou
down by the Gulf states you would see
the first outbreaks of spotty cases of
poliomyelitis the infection would spread
through the Gulf region up to the
landlocked states of the deep south and
often just ride the Mississippi straight
up north spreading out into into the
valley states and then off to the coasts
if you were a parent in New York and
Baltimore Sun Chicago somewhere to the
north you would see this viral storm
front you would see this viral storm
front gathering and know that you were
hopeless in the face of it you would
know that there was nothing you can do
if you lived in in if you're afraid of
earthquakes you either don't move to
California or you tell yourself probably
quite realistically that that the big
one won't strike in your time in the
case of polio it would always happen it
would happen every summer and it was a
case of pure arbitrariness as to whether
you or your child was going to be struck
also in both cases there was a
charismatic protagonist in the case of
Apollo 13 it was Jim Lovell in the case
of
of the polio story of course it's Jonas
Salk and what struck me about both
stories as well finally was that the
books could open with a cautionary tale
about what happens when everything goes
wrong in the case of Apollo 13 it was
the Apollo 1 fire that claimed the lives
of three astronauts on the launch pad
astronauts Grissom white and Chaffey in
1967 in the case of the Salk story it
was the polio epidemic of the summer of
1916 Jonas Salk was born at a very
auspicious time in history he was born
in 1914 in 1916 in New York City the
worst polio epidemic to date in the
history of the country struck in that
city and he was in the target
demographic he was in the sweet spot of
what the disease looked for two years
old and presumably with a vulnerable
immune system two years after that was
the great flu pandemic that killed 50
million people worldwide by the time
Jonas Salk was 41 years old he had
developed or code developed a vaccine
against both of those diseases but the
book nonetheless opens with the summer
of 1916 and I'm gonna read two very
short passages there was little that
parents or the city could do to protect
against the flu except beginning with
quarantine at sort of at the retail
level when influenza or when when polio
appeared in a house the house was
quarantined with it if it spread from
that house to the block the block was
quarantined and in often as not the city
would send black cars there only a
hundred and sixteen thousand cars
registered in in New York City at the
time and most of the ones that were
owned by the city that were shall act
over on the door with an emblem of the
city of New York we're seen as one of
the city's newest and modern
acquisitions and they became symbols
however of terror because the cars were
dispatched into the neighborhoods to
make spot checks on the polio houses and
houses that weren't complying with the
quarantine room rules would typically
lose their children the child would be
taken away to swine burn island off the
coast of Manhattan where child leader
would either recover or often does not
not recover
and this first passage was is tells a
bit about that story mothers did not
surrender their sick babies easily often
kicking and cursing the city physicians
as soon as they arrived things typically
went a bit smoother if a social worker
came along since the mothers seemed more
inclined to turn a child over to a woman
than to a man the absence of a social
worker usually meant that the doctor did
not intend to take the sick child away
though lately that had become an
unreliable sign since as the epidemic
progressed the city's overworked health
department simply had fewer of the
ladies to spare alone or unaccompanied
the doctor would walk quickly up the
steps to the house casting a fast glance
at the knot of mothers who stood
avoiding his eyes the first thing the
doctor would do when he entered a
paralysis home was look around the
parlor to determine whether the father
had taken to sleeping there if he had
that would count in the family's favor
the rules of the plague required that at
the initial signs of illness the child
and the mother retreat to the family
bedrooms and stay there until the
infectious phase of the disease had
passed the father who would have to
continue working and otherwise moving
through the community was to isolate
himself as well as he could this meant
that he was not to go up the stairs
beyond carrying up food and other
essentials and the mother and child were
not to come down until there was no risk
of either of them carrying the contagion
further if a cot and clothes and the
parlour convinced the doctor that the
father was complying with the
regulations he would next go up to the
bedrooms to examine the patient the
scene that greeted him there would
almost always be a bleak one by June was
proving to be a punishing summer with
temperatures typically rising high into
the 80s before noon and staying fixed
there until well after sundown the
bedrooms of poliomyelitis patients would
often be stifling since the windows
would be closed against the blue flies
stable flies and house flies that were
widely suspected of carrying the virus
the Health Department permitted
quarantine families to open their
windows if they had metal screens in
place but screens were expensive and not
always available in the room the child
would first get for the doctor would
first asked the mother to describe how
the child's illness had struck though he
knew what the answer would be the same
aches the same chills the same sudden
loss of strength
then he turned to the patient feeling
the child's head and neck to determine
if there was any fever he moved the legs
and arms to see if there was any pain he
bend the legs at the knees and asked the
child to push back to determine if there
was any lingering strength in the
muscles then he'd lay the limbs back
down if he concluded that the disease
was still burning inside the child and
that the parents had been sloppy about
the quarantine rules
he'd interpose himself between the
mother and the bed and gathered their
child up prepared to fight the curses
and kicks of the woman as he did
carrying the child downstairs he'd hoped
the father would restrain the mother to
say nothing of himself so that he could
take the patient to the car with a
minimum of unpleasantness if necessary
he would summon his driver whom he'd
have left behind the wheel for
assistance if that didn't work he'd
summon the police if on the other hand
the doctor found that the fever had
passed and that the house was well
sealed against leakage of the virus he'd
leave the home in peace the disease
after all would by now be through with
the child having entered and left
cutting a hot path through the spinal
cord along the way the wasted legs might
never be of any use again but the child
would no longer be a danger to anyone
else if the doctor did announce that the
child could stay the mother would cover
her face with her hands in relief when
the doctor clumped back down the stairs
with no child in his arms the grateful
father would often is not offer up an
impulsive gift the cigar man would
insist that the doctor take a cigar the
boot man would offer him laces the Baker
would offer him a ring of cake they
pressed the unwanted tributes on the
doctor and he would mostly take them
once in his car he'd passed them on to
his driver this went on throughout much
of the summer with children being taken
first to swine burn Island and then when
that was filled to other other
facilities in outside of Manhattan and
outside of Brooklyn in the other
boroughs down to Staten Island sometimes
which at the time was called Richmond
which I found rather charming and later
toward the end of the summer taken all
the way out to Woodmere in Long Island
where a hospital was built to care for
for crippled children and to to research
the disease that hospital was also
filled before before
September came one of the great ironies
of polio was that it was paradoxically a
disease of good sanitation polio has
been with us for thousands of years or
had been with us for thousands of years
one of the the earliest indications of
it was an Egyptian carving of a young
man with a withered right leg that
looked for all the world like a leg that
had been stricken by polio carrying a
walking stick there is virtually no
other disease known that causes
precisely that kind of kind of atrophy
but pulley only appeared very spottily
very sporadically until indoor plumbing
and and comparatively modern sanitation
were developed prior to that children
were routinely exposed to low background
levels of polio and throughout the early
years of their lives that would pick up
tiny subclinical cases of it that would
lead to a bit of a cold a bit of a flue
a bit of a fever something that looked a
little like polio but maybe wasn't quite
and then would pass as quickly as a cold
well a few of these that in fact were
polio and you develop a good robust
immunity against the disease once you
establish indoor plumbing though you
take away that low background exposure
then you get into your second year third
year fifth year sixth year of life you
have an immune system that's naked to
the virus and when a truly lethal strain
of the virus comes along you're knocked
flat it's no coincidence that the first
place there was ever an epidemic was
Stockholm in 1887 when there were 44
children children struck by polio about
15 years later a thousand kids and were
struck by polio in Stockholm and by 1916
in the u.s. 25,000 people were hit the
second short section I want to read
deals with what what the city of New
York and other cities by implication in
the summer of 1916 33 states were
affected but what the city of New York
in this case did when quarantine rolls
house-to-house quarantine rules failed
and how the city itself tried to try to
clamp down on the spread of the virus
the 4th of July was a predictably
festive day in New York and this year
was no exception with more than 500
patriotic meetings to be held
the borough's electric signs had been
erected at City Hall and in Times Square
Columbus Circle and City College Stadium
spelling out patriotic messages from the
mayor the governor and President Wilson
himself in incandescent bulbs that would
blaze with a brightness of 55 million
candles a great deal of work had gone
into planning such a day and a great
deal of it would now have to be undone
on the afternoon of July 2nd the health
commissioner Haven Emerson known mostly
for being the gentle great nephew of
author and poet Ralph Waldo Emerson
called his assistance into his office in
the Municipal Building on Center Street
in Manhattan it was a hot and gummy day
with her thermometer climbing to 84
degrees and not showing any sign of
falling at the Polo Grounds on the
northwestern edge of Manhattan barely
15,000 people showed up to watch the
Giants fall to the despised Brooklyn
Dodgers most of them leaving early to
escape the afternoon Sun as often
happened when the temperature rose the
paralysis bug thrived and throughout the
day hospitals around the city were
knocked back on their heels as
seventy-two stricken children were
rushed in for care by their parents more
than 20 of those patients already seemed
certain to die
Emerson reviewed the numbers from both
the hospitals and the Weathermen and
issued a series of orders of the 60
biggest celebrations planned for the
night of the 4th 15 would be canceled
plans for sidney city sponsored open-air
movies we would also be scrapped
children under 16 years of age would be
banned from all places where large
crowds gathered including movie houses
and theaters exhibitors or other
businesses caught disobeying the new
regulations would be stripped of their
operator's licenses more than half a
million leaflets would immediately be
printed and distributed explaining once
again how to follow the paralysis
hygiene guidelines Emerson's rolls went
promptly into effect and the polio bug
slapped them aside as the week pressed
on and the temperature stay at high 113
new cases checked into hospitals on July
5th and 87 followed on July 6 for every
5 cases at least one proved lethal
within the first two days as the muscles
that controlled the children's breath
failed along with the ones that control
their arms and legs when the weekend
arrived the numbers fell and parents
were briefly hopeful but it was a false
hope a result merely of spotty reporting
as the case counters in the hospital
took their Saturdays and Sundays off
when Monday arrived in the 3-day told
was tallied the counts soared again
in the neighborhoods terrorized New
Yorkers began freelancing solutions cats
many people concluded were responsible
for spreading the bug and so cats were
bludgeoned and drowned by the tens of
thousands when word got out that there
was a bounty on the animals heads boys
in Brooklyn rounded them up and brought
them hissing and scratching to the Board
of Health when that word turned out to
be a mere rumor the boys killed the cats
themselves in houses where polio had
already struck the animals were murdered
with special fury flung by rage blind
parents into the rivers sometimes when
the cats were already dead sometimes
when they were still alive
more than 70,000 cats were killed that
week but even after they were gone the
epidemic roared on if cats weren't
responsible the people concluded perhaps
mosquitoes were if it wasn't mosquitoes
it was rats or sewers are they always
dirty Gowanus Canal New Yorkers called
cabled and wrote the Department of
Health with all manner of other things
they were certain was causing the
paralysis plague including high ground
water ice cream cones excavations flies
bed bugs street dust corn flakes the
subway parasites and the water alloys
and cooking utensils gases from you
nisshin's factories the bent-over
position children assumed at school
desks mercury poisoning white clothing
earthquakes volcanoes electrical
disturbances sunburn intestinal
derangements second-hand bedding decayed
food excessive glare unclean milk
bottles carrying coins in the mouth and
tobacco with so many possible sources of
infection more and more people decided
to quit the city altogether in train
terminals in all the boroughs mothers
and children who had the means began
fleeing in numbers that judging by
railroad ticket sales exceeded 50,000
the actual count was probably far higher
since children under five travelled for
free meaning that there was no complete
tally of just how fast the city was
hemorrhaging its young for all this the
paralysis count still climbed in the
first four week of July 552 children
fell ill in the second week the tally
approached 1,000 at the peak of the
epidemic the worst year of an epidemic
of the polio epidemic in the
was 1952 when nearly 58,000 children
were sickened or killed which is
significantly more than the the toll of
all of the deaths in Vietnam and that
was in in just one summer one of the
things that I'm say one or two more
quick things then I'd love to open it up
for questions one of the things that
struck me the most about Jonas Salk was
his single mindedness and the clarity
with which he saw things the the anyone
who's done research before and we were
talking about this a little bit today
knows that collections of documents
personal collections of paper are kept
in file boxes about this big and as a
way I imagine of terrifying the people
who want access to those boxes the
finding aids are listed not so much in a
number of boxes but in linear feet of
shelf space consumed by the by the
collection the Salk collection was over
750 linear feet of shelf space which was
about six hundred and eighty four boxes
papers files documents letters memos lab
notes in all of those I came away with
one impression first of all Jonas Salk
did not doodle anywhere I was astounded
I looked at page after page after page
of lab notes nothing the only thing
close I found - it was on what looked to
be a scratch pad and he must have been
on the phone and I saw a triangle with
two lines in it and I thought this is it
the entire body of Jonas Salk's artwork
there's going to be a retrospective at
the Whitney next week I think but it
took that kind of ferocious
single-mindedness to do what he did he
had to and we can perhaps get into this
in a moment but in order to develop a
polio vaccine he had to flip on its head
how a vaccine was developed and how a
vaccine was made effective and how you
didn't make a vaccine he came up against
scientific orthodoxy he came up against
medical wisdom he came up against
science itself it was politics there was
money there were an enormous number of
things involved and when I looked at
these boxes and looked at what he did I
realized this was an act of scientific
pointillism this was an act of of mosaic
work a tiny brushstroke at a time when I
would get into the middle of a folder of
a
notebook that was just page after page
of incomprehensible glyphs to me and the
only sense I could make of it was what
was written at the top was that it was a
single test of a single formulation for
toxicity of an oil fortification in a
vaccine in the kidneys of lab mice mice
3 through 28 and there were 1,500 mice
tested I realized that the level of
detail and level of foresight you have
to say to say I can immerse myself in
the kidney of this Mouse and fill a
notebook with it because I know
somewhere down the line this is one tiny
tile in this vast mosaic of work I'm
trying to put together to conquer polio
and to do it coming up against
scientific orthodoxy just before I went
to a reading last night in New York at
Barnes & Noble my older daughter ELISA
who's four years old said something that
really strike struck me and every parent
thinks their children are precious and
pre she and mine are but everybody
thinks that but she was sitting in my
room as I was getting ready to go and I
just reached over and turned my alarm
clock toward me and she said why did you
turn the clock and I said well to see
what time it is and she said to me and
to see what time it's not I said well
yeah sure I mean that goes without
saying by implication there are many
more times it's not then times there or
it is but that I think is with Salk and
people like him were able to do you look
at the clock and you also see what time
it's not he was able to turn things on
their head to say here we are and I'm
gonna stand outside and see what else
there is to learn by not looking at
what's obvious that's what struck me
about him and that's what brought me to
this story and I'd love to take any
questions at all anyone anyone might
have yes
they were like Betty and Veronica if
anyone read Archie comics they did not
get along and they didn't get along for
two reasons first of all they didn't get
get along temperamentally Sabin was a
very acerbic man an exceedingly cutty
man cutting man incredibly articulate if
you got if you didn't agree with Albert
Sabin if you didn't understand something
he was saying he'd approach you less
with with confusion that with a sort of
disdainful pity and this came across and
his dealings with people he was very
lusty about conflict about about
engaging in the cut and thrust of of
scientific debate Salk was exceedingly
conflict averse he didn't like
confronting people about things it's a
hard thing when what you've done is when
you've when you decide you're gonna be
an unorthodox scientist but he didn't
like confronting people about things so
he was sort of sidestep things today
we'd call it passive-aggressive back
then we just called it you know cautious
and diplomatic so they clashed at that
level they clashed at the temperamental
level they also clash most importantly
at the level of scientific ideology Salk
bullets the the received wisdom before
Salk started working on this was if
there's one way to make a vaccine
against a virus based disease you weaken
the virus and then you inject it into a
person into a body a weakened virus
cannot cause a disease but it's enough
to wake up the immune system it
recognizes the disease and it develops a
standing army of antibodies so anytime a
wild virus comes along they're ready for
it
problem with weakened viruses is they
can mutate back and there were often
cases of vaccine associated disease
either in the person who had received it
or in people around that person because
when the vaccine when the virus passes
through the body it often mutates in a
single passage through the body from
safety to virulence Salk thought that's
madness to do that with polio if you're
talking about the common cold if you're
talking even about influenza you can
survive all of those things with with
few consequences polio he wasn't willing
to try it on he said I'm gonna kill the
virus
I'm gonna do it that way and I'm gonna
prove that you can make a vaccine that's
as effective or perhaps more effective
than a attenuated virus vaccine with a
killed virus science said it couldn't be
done that getting the immune system to
hunt a dead virus was a little bit like
getting a fox to hunt a dead hound
it'll sniff around at it but it's
definitely not gonna launch a vigorous
attack so the two of them battled on
that and they were friendly and very
oftentimes not friendly rivals straight
up through through the rest of their
lives actually because both vaccines
were ultimately developed yes what was
the transition between the influenza and
the the polio vaccine what what caused
him to shift it was mostly it wasn't so
much a change in interest he had
developed him and his mentor Tommy
Francis had developed the influenza
vaccine and it wasn't so much a change
of interest or or a desire to go you
know I've got one disease to my name now
I'm gonna go bag another as much as it
was that he simply wanted to go out on
his own he he told dr. Francis that
that's what he wanted to do he said to
him his mentor said you're ready for
that you can do it but make sure you get
a good billet somewhere he tried a
number of glamorous assignments at some
West Coast universities East Coast
universities he felt there was some
element of anti-semitism involved there
may well have been at that point it was
it was fairly open and and fairly
flagrant he was ultimately invited out
to to the University of Pittsburgh which
was considered just an unspeakable place
to work it was a man he knew a guy named
Walter Schlessinger had worked there
quit the university in disgust he he was
head of the then University of
Pittsburgh virus lab which was
essentially a largely empty room in an
abandoned morgue in the basement of the
building when you've abandoned a morgue
when a morgue won't even live there you
got real estate problems the morgue left
this was Salk's lab it was essentially
unfunded it was essentially empty
Pittsburgh at the time was a
course the smokey City when men would
have to take two shirts to work one to
wear in the morning and one to change
into an midday because the shirt would
have turned black or at least gray by
midday they had the Pirates who never
won there just wasn't anything to
recommend Pittsburgh
he Saul came back and and said I'm gonna
take this job and his mentor said oh
you've got to be kidding what's there
and Salk said the words that I've heard
quoted many many times he said I know at
the moment it's just empty rooms and
promises but I just fell in love with
the place once he got there he still
wasn't sure what he was gonna do it was
either gonna be polio but even then he
wasn't thinking of a vaccine he was just
thinking of some tests and some other
basic study in polio so you're gonna be
that cold vaccine or measles vaccine and
shortly after we arrived he was
approached by sort of the the the minor
league talent scout of the National
Foundation of infantile paralysis who
was a man named Harry Weaver who was
known for collecting great talent and
the NFIP which is the organization was
founded by Roosevelt after he contracted
polio and later became the March of
Dimes it was they were looking to they
were beginning a program to type the
virus to make sure they that there were
only three types of polio virus because
before you could even consider a vaccine
you got to know how many types of virus
you have it does nobody any good if you
say there are three types of polio virus
and we've got killed sample of each of
those three viruses in this shot and
then you find out there are types four
or five and six out there so they had to
make sure that only three types existed
it was grueling just rote work you would
give it to a grad student and say call
me in two years if you're still alive
it's just it's a horrible tedious job
Salk took it on and three other labs
took it on and once he was done with
that he had sort of earned his first
polio stripes and he said this is what
I'm gonna do I'm gonna develop a vaccine
it was around 1947 1948